man I want to talk to you about what
what you went through because you know
we're talking about this Farm all the
big Pharma stuff
but I'm curious when all the lockdowns
happened there were a handful of
businesses that stood up and said no
what you you ran one of these businesses
that the government
tried to shut down you resisted and the
first thing I just want to say is this
is a story that I'm excited for you to
tell because we've long told people
non-violence of a Disobedience stand up
for what you believe in file the
lawsuits file the complaints make them
work for their their oppression or
whatever and you will win and you won
they try to shut you down they they hurt
your business they hurt you
but then in the end you ended up winning
out so let's uh tell us exactly what
went down with your business how that
how that started yeah well so as soon as
Kobe start I was actually at the at the
time I was still working as an
intelligence analyst for the military
just to supplement my income you know
because when you when you start a
restaurant you're not Off to the Races
you know automatically making money
so when covet happened in March of 2020
they shut my entire program down that I
was working on and I was working on a uh
a pretty intense a pretty serious
program and uh that had a lot of
National Security implications so when
they sent all of us home and they shut
the entire skiff down I paid attention
and I said well this must be something
serious this must be a virus that's
going to kill half the world like
they're saying so I took it serious and
uh I I listened to the recommendations
of at that time Governor Northam and I
shut my restaurant down took a step back
because I wanted to be responsible and
didn't want to put my customers In
Harm's Way nobody knew at that time what
was going on
so
it wasn't long after that maybe a month
or so that I started to realize
something weird was going on and then
three months after June of 2020 Governor
Northam said okay restaurants you can
open back up but under these provisions
and that's when it clicked I said wait a
minute
this is more about control than it is
our health and safety and it was because
they put mandates in place like you have
to wear a mask when you walk in the
restaurant but as soon as you sit down
somehow you're safe from covid and
nobody's allowed to sit at my bar but I
can pull the table up to the bar and uh
you can sit there and my bartender
couldn't hand the drink over the bar my
bartender had to walk around the bar and
serve it to the person side by side just
very arbitrary uh mandates that made
absolutely no sense and uh so like I
said I spent my entire adult life
fighting dictatorships overseas and I
wasn't going to come home and allow a
dictatorship to rule so I did the only
thing I could do and that was fight back
by not complying Civil Disobedience and
I kind of
did that kind of under the radar uh at
first I didn't announce it my customers
just knew that when they came to gore
melts they were walking in to uh what
America used to be pre-coveted they were
walking into Freedom a safe space a safe
space there you go and uh and I operated
that way actually from June of 2020 to
January of 2021. I would get a call from
uh from the health department maybe once
a month or so and they would say hey
Matt we uh we got a call from one of
your customers that said you're not
following covet mandates and I would
never confirm or deny it and at that
time the Health Inspectors they weren't
allowed to come out and inspect so none
of them ever came came out to my
restaurant so I would just say oh well
thanks for the call I appreciate that
and they would just say oh yeah you know
just you know follow covet mandates and
I'm like okay cool whatever
and uh and it went like that until
January 2021 now what happened in in
January was Biden took office
and when he took office as you guys know
he started firing off all of these
executive orders one of those executive
orders mandated OSHA come out in
conjunction with local Health
departments and shut down restaurants
specifically that weren't following
covet mandates and that's when I got my
first visit from the the health
department and OSHA
and they said hey Matt you're not
following coven mandates and I said no
no I'm not I said because they don't
make any sense I said if you can make
them make sense to me comments because
I'm all about common sense I've never
been a very political guy I've never
trusted politicians on either side of
the aisle to be honest with you and uh
and and I just want things that make
sense and what he told me is really what
set the wheels in motion he said well
Matt it doesn't have to make sense the
governor said you have to do it so you
have to do it and at that point I said
absolutely not this is not how things
work in America
and he said well we'll come back and uh
we'll suspend your your health
department license and I said well you
do what you have to do but I'm going to
do what I know I have to do and uh and
that is afford my customers their
constitutional rights and at that point
I told him I said at this point you were
trespassing so if you don't leave my
property I'll have you removed any left
but he he made good on his promise and
he came back about two weeks later
served me with the suspension papers
suspended my health department license
and in the state of Virginia
if your health department license is
suspended your alcohol license your ABC
license is automatically suspended so I
lost both of those that day
and I continued to to operate business
as usual I didn't comply and at that
point I made a video and uh and I put it
out to the public what was going on and
I let them know that I would not be
compliant and uh the main reason is
because like I said before spent a lot
of my time a lot of my adult life
fighting overseas and I have a lot of
brothers that went overseas with me and
didn't make it back a lot of guys that
died over there and their kids are
growing up right now here in the United
States of America because they felt that
America was more important than their
life so if I'm not willing to put my
livelihood on the line when those guys
were willing to put their life on the
line then what kind of man am I and my
wife and I we always teach our kids to
do what's right no matter what the
personal cost is to them so how in the
hell are we going to teach them that if
we're not willing to do the same thing
ourself so those are the main reasons
why I fought back and because I did that
uh they they sued me Governor Northern
sued me and he took me to court and
tried to shut my business down but I
didn't back down and it was overwhelming
the response from the community that
showed up after that I mean I had people
coming from Across the Nation to support
me I had one guy come all the way I
remember from Iowa
now my restaurant gourmeltz is right off
of Interstate 95 in Virginia not even a
mile from the exit so it's uh it's very
convenient so I get a lot of people that
come by all the time just passing
through so this guy came up to me and uh
he said hey I'm from Iowa and I said
well you're just passing through or what
and he said nope I flew out here just to
come to your restaurant and shake your
hand and look you in the eye and thank
you for what you were doing and he
started crying and and that right there
Amanda got me it let me knew it let me
know at that point that I was doing the
right thing
because when you make a decision like my
wife and I made which was to fight back
you know you have no idea which way it's
going to go uh we thought it was going
to be the end of uh of our business we
thought it was going to be at the end of
everything we worked our entire life for
but the community showed up and they
supported us and we had a line out the
door from open to close and by 7 PM we
had no food left wow all we had was
bread and people were walking up to the
register saying give me a piece of bread
and I'll pay full price for it wow it's
amazing and it just it blew my mind and
uh and we continued to fight back and uh
and I reached out to my my uh my
Republican representatives in Virginia
because they're supposed to be
conservative Patriots that stand for the
Constitution and all I was doing was
standing for the Constitution standing
for my customers constitutional rights
and uh and I was very disappointed that
none of my Republican Representatives
reached back out to me
and so
long story short I I said how do I get
rid of these scumbags how do I make sure
because they run around saying Democrats
are ruining the country and they are
but these Republicans that are sitting
on their hands not willing to step up
and fight for you and me they're no
better than those Democrats that's the
establishment we talk about the unit
party is absolutely real
in the end you end up you got your back
your liquor license your health license
and all that stuff well so so what
happened is uh we go to court for with
the health department
and uh and I beat the health department
in court I proved that these mandates
were in fact unconstitutional and they
had to give me my health department
license back good so the next step was
uh the ABC we go before the ABC Board to
get my abc license back and we thought
it would be you know cut and dry open
and shut hey you took my abc license
only because the Virginia Department of
Health took my health department license
well we beat them in court and they had
to give me that license back so now in
turn you should have to give me my abc
license back makes sense right yeah
well it's a very liberal ABC Board now
at this time we had a change of
Governors in Virginia
uh so Governor younke took over so now
Ralph Northam is no longer the uh the
governor
uh we got a republican governor
Republican lieutenant governor and
Republican Attorney General
so I go before the ABC Board and it's a
very liberal ABC Board and what they
said was in a nutshell basically was
Matt didn't matter that you beat the
Department of Health and that's the only
reason we took your license it doesn't
matter that the reason they took it was
unconstitutional all that matters is we
took it and you didn't comply and that
word comply kept coming up and they said
so for that reason we're not going to
give you your license back and I said
well Roger that then I don't need a
license and I continue to sell alcohol
without it wow and I immediately as soon
as uh Glenn young took office I reached
out to him and I heard nothing back from
him we all saw the video where you're
filming and the ABC guys come in and the
cops come in and they're they're raiding
and looting your private property of
alcohol what so what finally happened
what is this
yeah well the reason they came out and
raided my place is because like I said I
was reaching out to the governor since
uh he took office and by that time I
announced my run for state senate to uh
come crush the establishment and
Republican leadership they don't like
when a republican candidate speaks out
against other Republicans but uh I have
no idea why you should speak out against
any politician that's not doing their
job so for that reason they didn't reach
out and help me they left me to the
wolves and I heard nothing back from the
governor's office or the Attorney
General's office until December 2nd of
2022 this past December when the
Virginia State Police and the Virginia
ABC agents came and raided my restaurant
and took every drop of alcohol out of my
restaurant that's where you're at right
now what well so that's the viral video
that uh that you guys saw and and so
what happened after that is uh
we were going back and forth and they
were trying to settle with me but I've
always stayed strong in my stance and
that I will not settle with you I didn't
do anything illegal I didn't do anything
wrong what what settled what kind of
settle do they want at this point I mean
the whole thing's over yeah well so you
know they've always you know they they
were offering me you know hey Matt
instead of 90 days of suspension and a
fifteen thousand dollar fraud or
whatever it was uh no suspension of your
license and just give us two thousand
dollars oh my goodness a little
extortion a little Shakedown yeah
exactly and it's all about them wanting
to get a win and that's it and uh so I
said listen I stood strong paid no
settlement at all and they kept coming
back with settlement office settlement I
said you know what I will settle with
you
I said I'll pay you 17.76
and I was hoping like hell they took
that just to remind them of Freedom this
is like Michael Corley Corleone when he
says you know my off I offer is this
nothing that's right so of course they
didn't take it and uh
and I said well listen man you guys
aren't getting a dime from me
I am not going to serve a suspension and
I'll tell you what
after I reopened my restaurant for
Christmas because I'll be closed for
Christmas when I reopened after
Christmas I'm gonna open my bar back up
and I'm going to sell alcohol and I'm
operating business as usual
and magically before I close for
Christmas December 23rd and I told him I
said Hey listen if uh if Glenn yakin and
uh and and the rest of the Republican
leadership in Virginia if you guys are
ready for the political storm that
follows you arresting a small business
owner who is also a veteran that fought
for his country if you're ready for that
political shitstorm I'm ready to go to
jail because a lot of my brothers were
ready to die for this country and they
did so I've been ready to die from my
country since I was 17 years old so I'm
I'm damn sure ready to go to jail for my
country so at that point it was uh it
was a Mexican standoff man and uh and
they folded December 23rd they gave me
all of my alcohol back they gave me my
abc license back and I didn't pay a dime
when did we go down there what was that
that was before this right that was
before that so you remember we were
planning a party right right yeah so I I
told you I said hey Tim this is my plan
I said regardless of what happens the
the day we open after Christmas we're
going to be selling alcohol man let's
throw a party down here and we were
planning that yeah and uh and magically
they uh they said I you know what never
mind they tapped out and they said uh
they brought your booze back December
23rd you get everything back yeah wow
but you would have made them look so bad
yeah I mean you made them look bad and
good what yeah very what happened like
in the early days when you were
resisting the initial stuff what was the
process day one you didn't shut down
were they like finding you every day and
then and in retrospect they just
dismissed the fines what was happening
day to day yeah I feel other people are
going through this yeah I mean it was it
was so I was fined over seventy thousand
dollars by OSHA for having an unsafe
work environment was that a day by day
fine that added up it was just arbitrary
fines that they just made up so like
they sent me this piece of paper that
said oh hey Matt uh for not making
people wear a mask we're finding you
twenty thousand dollars for not putting
up plexiglass we're finding you thirty
five thousand dollars or whatever it was
where the hell did you get that where'd
you get those numbers from where you
just made them up and where'd you get
these regulations yeah I mean they're
totally arbitrary plexiglass is gonna do
something yeah it just insane so when
when that ocean inspector actually came
out to my restaurant he said you got to
put plexiglass up I said Okay I want to
know the regulation
how wide does the plexiglass have to be
and they said well actually in the
regulation there's nothing that says how
wide it has to be I said well so you're
telling me if I put a one inch strip of
plexiglass up I'm technically in
compliance and he said well technically
yeah
and I said listen take your OSHA hat off
for one second and just talk to me
man-to-man does that make any sense to
you and again he said Matt it doesn't
have to make sense that's what they said
so you have to do it and uh psychotic
that's not how the American government
is supposed to work that's how they work
that's how they do it and that's what we
signed up for what my story proves what
it proves is that if you stand up and
you fight back no matter how much they
try to back you into a corner and bully
you if we stand together because I
wouldn't have won this by myself if it
was just me Matt Strickland fighting I'd
be in prison right now but the people of
America stood with me from Across the
Nation I mean they came out of the
Woodworks and supported me and the only
thing that politicians the only thing
that they answer to is political
pressure and uh I mean everybody knows
Glenn young is trying to run for
president now and so they inundated his
office with emails and phone calls he
couldn't make a social media post
without somebody jumping on his post
saying hey what about Matt Strickland
what about Gourmet
and uh and they cave to that political
pressure they didn't want to help me
because I stand up against not only
Democrats but Republicans also
um but the the political pressure was
enough from across the nation that they
had no choice but to act I think part of
what's what's what's great about the
story is too you were willing to comply
in the early days in the very beginning
when you didn't know if it was Airborne
Ebola where people were gonna their skin
was gonna start melting off you didn't
know and you were ready to make the
sacrifice for the betterment of the
people and then when the evidence starts
coming in then then you're it's like
okay now realism and Common Sense takes
over as it did in the beginning too I
think that's why I was willing to shut
down for two weeks but to slow the
spread but yeah on top of that it's you
you'd walk into a restaurant
and they would you'd walk in the front
door and they would say please put on a
mask you'd say okay you put it on they'd
hand hand you one right you'd wear it
and they say now the chair right next to
you please sit and take the mask off
right and you take it off throw in the
garbage and then you're supposed to put
it back on to walk to the bathroom do
you remember this you were supposed to
put it back onto it we had a we had a
plan here we never got around to because
you know in West Virginia it was fairly
lacks and then they ended up lifting it
but what we wanted to do is get full
hazmat suits nice walk in sit down take
the full suit off
you know like go to your table take the
full suit off place it on the chair next
to you sit down order food and then go
I'm gonna run to the bathroom real quick
put the full suit back on zip it up and
then walk slowly and awkwardly just to
make the point yeah it's like there's
that comic where the person's walking in
the covet virus hits him in the face and
that's just I'm sitting down with like a
green
exactly it's interesting too how you
talk about how it was June 2020 that
they said you could open your restaurant
again and they hit you with all of these
arbitrary arbitrary restrictions of what
you had to do in your restaurant that's
of course after George Floyd was killed
and it was after the entire government
of all the blue States decided that um
you can't get covet if you're protesting
for black lives matter but you can get
coveted if you go to a restaurant that
doesn't have Plexiglas you know what you
should have done you should have just
put up a BLM flag
and then they'd say you know what you're
good no fine for you they would have
been okay with that yeah I mean it's
funny you guys say that because
of course I was trashed online for not
following coven mandates and people who
have never met me a day in my life uh
were saying all kinds of things about me
and somehow just because I didn't make
people wear a mask when they walked into
my restaurant I was racist
I knew I knew that was coming too it's
always it's always racist whatever
whatever when you don't comply when you
don't just do what you're told then
you're racist as though as though
there's all these you know as though
there's no black people who want to
stand up for their rights it feels like
aliens are trying to control us but
don't quite understand humans like well
humans don't like being called racist so
no matter what they do call it racists
is like andrael is not aliens it's
children it's it's you know you know the
best part about the internet is on the
internet you you're not aware you're
arguing with a 14 year old yeah they're
adult men
in their 40s who work for major news
outlets who go on Twitter and there's an
account called like you know Trump Maga
300 and it'll be a picture of trump
going like yeah and then it'll say
something like you're stupid your
politics are bad and they'll be like
who's this guy you're so you can't say
that to me and it's like a 14 year old
kid who's just laughing I have no idea
what's going on he's like they could
even be 11. it could be like a 11 year
old kid it could be my kid yeah just
goofing off on the internet don't even
care these people take it so seriously I
had so one of my uh the DDM on my team
in Iraq the sniper
he uh when we'd have down time he'd go
on and play Call of Duty and uh I
remember when he told me one one morning
he was he was arguing with like a 12
year old on Call of Duty who he showed
me crazy look at this dude look what
he's saying man you suck you have no
idea what real Combat is you don't know
how to shoot that's what the kid was
saying to him the dude is a sniper you
know what I mean you know looking back
over the last couple years for yourself
is there anything that you would have
done or or would change have changed in
the process I know it seems to have
turned out extremely well but for people
in the future that are willing to stand
up you know and prevent to create Civil
Disobedience yeah which is there
anything that you can help with yeah
well first of all
what I would have done earlier is pay
attention to politics
um I I uh I did not pay attention to
politics like I do now and uh and I
running for state senate now and if
anybody wants to follow my journey on
that um they can follow me on social
media at Matt for VA
um and my website's matt4va.com if you
want to see how that turns out but I'm
ashamed to say and I was telling you
guys this before the show the first time
I ever voted was in 2020 and the reason
for that is because I don't trust
politicians on either side of the aisle
and so pay attention to politics
especially on the state level because
that's where you make your money but as
far as fighting against coveted mandates
and such I truly believe it'll happen
again maybe not in the same shape and
form that happened this last time but
the government trying to take control of
our rights I mean so what are the
mandates in Virginia was you weren't
allowed to leave your house between the
hours of midnight and 5 a.m how is that
curbing covid how does that do anything
remember the guy on the beach he was
arrested for surfing by himself remember
the video where the guy's jogging in the
beach and the cop chases after him and
the jogger just speeds up yeah he just
bolts and the cop can't catch him it's
just insane that sounds more like an
anti-rioting thing yeah it just makes no
sense so what I would say is what you
need to do the next time something
doesn't feel right is trust your gut and
you need to stand up and you need to
fight back from the beginning and not
only that
everybody needs to support you
especially small business owners you
would be surprised how many
restaurateurs in the state of Virginia I
had called me as soon as they heard
about my story and they would say hey
Matt thank you so much for standing up
and doing what you're doing I'm totally
behind you 100 what can I do to support
you and I would tell each and every one
of them if you believe in what I'm doing
the best thing you can do to support me
is do the same thing and they would all
say the same thing they wouldn't do it
not me I don't want the health
department breathing down my neck man
and I said listen
with that attitude they're going to be
breathing down your neck the rest of
your life man well wasn't that the
shocking thing too was how many people
just did comply it was I I found that so
stunning how many Americans just sucked
it up and did what they were told and I
found that extremely disappointing for
my fellow countrymen to watch them just
like capitulate and do what the
government told them to do it's like
that's not what we're founded on we're
founded on telling the government
exactly that we're not going to do what
they tell us to I feel like video games
has made people really willing to comply
because in a game there's a structure
and a set of rules that you cannot
bypass you're stuck within yeah yeah
this this realm if then but in reality
you have complete Freedom you can do any
go anywhere see anything interact with
anything I just started watching have
you guys seen 1883 negative I haven't
seen Yellowstone but uh we're having
dinner and everyone's like you got to
watch it 1083 songs
and uh it's there's a really great scene
where
the uh there's like it's a bunch of
German people and they're trying to get
to Oregon because Paradise they hear
and they they gotta cross a river and so
the you know the Marshall guy or
whatever his name is he's like you guys
uh swim in Germany I was like no it's
illegal and he's like it's illegal to
swim in Germany and then he gets angry
and he's like everything I don't think
he says Jeremy says it's illegal to swim
where I'm from it's like everything is
illegal where I'm from like that's why
we're leaving and it's it's crazy think
about that that's for a lot of people
that we're leaving Europe and coming to
emptiness conflict and death it was
because it was better than having the
government live to live with the
government's boot on your neck I
actually just showed uh my son the other
night the movie Brazil you remember that
movie
it's I think it's Terry Gilliam is that
that's a person right I'm pretty sure
it's his movie but um it's basically
it's about this guy who works for the
government and it's just all red tape
and bureaucracy and all he does he has
his he has his dreams you know and he
like lives in a fantasy kind of but at
the end at a certain point we'll give it
away but he ends up
um sort of outside of the city he gets
up away from the paperwork and you just
see this these mountains and you're just
you could it's like you can finally
breathe watching the movie I'm we're
doing a whole dystopia thing right like
he's reading 1984 we're gonna we're
gonna do all of it Fahrenheit 451 but
the other thing that you were talking
about in terms of the coveted
restrictions and how that was used and
these restaurant tours are going to have
the government breathing down their
necks the rest of their lives there's a
lot of um officials around the world not
necessarily in the US although I think
probably in the bid Administration there
are who see a lot of this coved
lockdowns and restrictions almost as a
blueprint of how they can
um coerce the population into submitting
to climate change mitigation measures
the German Health Minister was talking
about this a year ago and I think you
know Jack pesobic was fact checked for
saying that this was happening but it
Avid actually was happening and they say
things like you know the kind of
restrictions that we used for covid we
can ask people to do that to mitigate
climate change we can ask corporations
to tell their workers to work from home
we can ask them not to take business
trips not to travel as much as they
would like to curb this climate thing so
yeah I mean they're going to use these
same methods over again you know they're
going to use it for whatever new crisis
they come up with and what we see from
the left what we see from Democrats is a
willingness and insistence to rule US
based on crises it's always a crisis I
want to insert the left it's just people
that are with their head down like
you're saying you know governments of
the Republicans that makes sense too but
I mean that's the that's the methodology
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time